here in Germany Russia's war on Ukraine
and its economic Fallout is likely to
stay top of the political agenda in
2023. Chancellor Schultz's government
has already pushed through relief
packages to help offset Rising Energy
prices for Germans it's feared the
economic pinch could undermine public
support for the government's Ukraine
policies here's DW's Chief political
correspondent Nina haza with more
when spring 23 comes the first big
question will be did the German
government do enough to get Germans
through this winter okay as Chancellor
shots promised
people do consume more gas and
electricity when it's cold after all
will consumers and companies have been
able to cope with the high energy prices
and with inflation and what about energy
security
will spend much of his second year in
office trying to replace Russian energy
sources just like he did in his first
year following Russia's large-scale
invasion of Ukraine but will that come
at the detriment of the country's
climate goals which brings me to the
second big challenge of 2023 Olaf shirts
needs to keep Germans convinced that
solidarity with Ukraine has to continue
for as long as it takes
financial aid humanitarian AIDS and
weapons
we'll continue this support for as long
as it is needed
for as long as Russia doesn't withdraw
its troops that is a December poll
showed not even one in three East
Germans say Germany should show
solidarity with Ukraine even if that
comes with negative consequences like
high energy prices in West Germany the
number was slightly higher but still not
the majority of people
and while we're on that topic Olaf toys
needs to convince International partners
that Germany is reliable and can be
trusted when it comes to support of
Ukraine and that includes modernizing
the German Army which is a huge
challenge after years of neglect and all
our charts needs to keep the country
United
a foiled coup attempt in December
reminded everyone how real the threat
from right-wing extremism is in Germany
[Music]
the most important consequence is that
everyone knows that we have a state that
can defend itself we are a democracy
that can defend itself which can thwart
such violations of law such planning
with its security authorities and can
defend itself with full force
then of course there are the big
International challenges what is Russia
going to do next and Olaf child says he
wants to put a big focus on the
countries of the global South which are
becoming increasingly not just trade but
also strategic partners for Germany
that means you'll be doing a lot of
flying to have face time with leaders in
countries like Brazil and India
[Music]
Purity strategy has been spelled out and
that will happen early on in the year
and that is supposed to be followed by
Germany's New China strategy now some
are already ringing the alarm Bells
because of Germany's High dependency on
China Germany is an export-oriented
country roughly 1 million jobs depend on
trade with China here so what if
tensions rise between China and some of
its neighbors well that would be pure
speculation and let's face it the German
government looks busy enough as it is
[Music]
so given that Ukraine will continue to
be one of the German government's
greatest challenges this year I'm very
pleased to welcome Alexander Muller the
defense spokesman for the business
friendly FTP group in the German
Parliament the FTP is one of the
Coalition Partners in the current German
government thanks so much for being with
us Mr Miller
um some military experts say that
Ukraine can win the war in 2023 but only
if the West helps the country with
modern battle tanks is Germany prepared
to do that
Germany is prepared we have delivered a
lot of Weaponry to the Ukraine we are
number three in the world uh in the
volume of develop delivering weapons we
are struggling currently within the
Coalition you know about that about
heavy weapon heavy Weaponry like main
battle tanks
we are still discussing this but this is
something aside I think I can really say
we have delivered a lot
so what would you say about the recent
polls suggesting fewer people in Germany
support weapons deliveries to Ukraine do
you see a shift in in the feeling
amongst the German population
no um from the people I know and I speak
with I see no reduction in support for
Ukraine everybody knows how important it
is to support Ukraine it it is there's
something about our international law
Russia may not have any advantage of
attacking a peaceful neighbor Country
and this is a sign that must come from
from other parts of Ukraine so you feel
that even with the rising energy bills
the real you know the fact that Germans
lives are changing as a result of the
war you still feel that this support
will will stay steadfast
our lives are changing constantly and
even if we would now
um reduce sanctions for Russia the
prices for energy would not go down so
in any way we have to support Ukraine
and we have to hold on to the sanctions
to Russia
talk briefly about the the German Army
itself which was mentioned in the report
we just saw it's it struggled with
Hardware problems of its own just last
month all of its high-tech Puma tanks
broke down during an exercise that's
just one example of the challenges that
it's facing
how can the bundesphere the German Army
be modernized and be modernized quickly
the the biggest biggest problem in the
bundesphere is we have to improve
procurement our procurement in Buddhist
Ware is too slow too bureaucratic and we
already did last year some things we had
a new law the bundesliebers because
that's a long word this is but this is
just version one zero we have to improve
procurement even better we have to
become faster and that is the main
problem in in our bonus where even to
enhance availability of our weaponry
so you feel like that it's clear what
what has to happen do you think this
will happen
of course we are working on that the
ministry of defense is working on that
and we will make even more laws to
reduce bureaucracy uh to make it easier
to procure to um reduce the the layers
and the levels in procurement we have to
be much much faster and we're working on
that okay Mr Miller I do just want to
ask you Germany's defense minister
Christina lambrecht she's in charge of
modernizing the army just yesterday she
was facing calls for a resignation after
a New Year's message that many Saw as
ill-judged and inappropriate is she the
right person to lead the German Army
into the future in your opinion
we shouldn't judge her from social media
videos that she uh in her personal
accounts that she offers in her personal
account you know our economical Minister
uh spends 400 000 Euros uh just for a
photographer to put him in the right
light if we if we um look at our
ministers in in such a way that we um
yeah judge them from the social media
accounts everybody will have a high um
many people uh to to help them and that
costs a lot of money I think it is
unfair to uh
okay we'll have to leave it there but
thanks so much for your time Alexander
Muller defense spokesman for the FTP
group in the German Parliament